on
une personne handicapée comme une
personne valide a besoin aussi de faire
du sport de bouger et c'est pour pour se
remuscler pour aussi
pouvoir s'amuser et prendre du plaisir
n'est pas rare d'avoir des personnes qui
tournent autour et qui dit soi respect
c'est vraiment cool ce que vous faites
donc je pense qu'il ya peut-être aussi
une autre vision un dieu du sport quand
on nous voit et c'est dans un châssis et
on est des riders voilà comme comme les
autres le rider c'est à dans 30 ans et
6,2 wake lui pratique assis une leucémie
à l'âge de 4 ans et les jambes lâche
paraplégiques mais adam persévère à
force d'optimisme
l'adrénaline les copains
le fait de pouvoir aussi tenter des
choses qu'on tenterait pas si c'était du
béton voilà les petites rotations avec
la tête en bas c'est quand même quelque
chose de sympa
le wakeboard version parra c'est un peu
de logistique d'organisation mais c'est
du sport avec ses valeurs universelles
on n'a pas de raison de ne pas le faire
c'est riche pour tout le monde que ça
soit pour eux ou pour nous aussi moi
j'apprends beaucoup
ça prend beaucoup parce que c'est
d'aider belle leçon d'humilité il ya des
jours où j'ai pas envie d'aller dans
l'eau et moi je vais rester avec que j'y
vais quand même parce que 6,6 yvon
pourquoi je dirais pas donc moi je me
plains un petit peu de temps en temps je
me pointe je me plains un peu moins
quand les corps sont cabossés le
quotidien devient un défi et la vie une
bataille parfois rude mais avec aussi
ses petits moments à soi précieux juste
parce que le sport lui se joue bien du
destin
[Musique]